las cifras oficiales hablan de una
abstención del 35 por ciento y el
observatorio dice que fue al menos un 80
por ciento a qué se debe la diferencia
se debe a que precisamente el consejo
supremo electoral es una institución
cooptada por parte del partido de
gobierno así como todas las
instituciones del estado y la mayor
parte de los sectores sociales ya sean
públicos y privados el consejo supremo
electoral ha funcionado desde el
principio del proceso como un medio para
lograr el fraude y para legitimar de
manera fracasada claramente el poder
político que tiene el partido de
gobierno en nicaragua urnas abiertas se
ha registrado un 80 por ciento de
abstencionismo dadas las circunstancias
y la nula participación ciudadana en
este proceso de votación y que otras
irregularidades se evidenciaron en el
monitoreo que hizo el observatorio
bueno hemos encontrado reportes
ciudadanos relacionados con violencia
política y anomalías irregularidad e
irregularidades en los centros de
votación en todos los departamentos y
regiones autónomas del país hemos
encontrado irregularidades en más de 200
centros de votación anomalías vinculadas
con la presencia policial y sobre todo
la presencia policial armada hemos
encontrado
actividades proselitistas por parte del
partido de gobierno hemos encontrado
también asedio amenazas y hostigamiento
para que la ciudadanía se presentara en
las urnas y votará a favor del partido
de gobierno lo cual contraviene la
legislación nacional y cualquier
principio de elecciones democráticas y
con esta victoria del presidente daniel
ortega completará 20 años continuos en
el poder cuando termine su mandato en el
2027 que implica esto para nicaragua
bueno estamos experimentando ciertamente
uno de los momentos más oscuros de
nuestra historia dado que hemos
concluido el día de ayer el proceso
electoral viciado de origen marcado por
fuertes índices altos índices de
violencia política y graves afectaciones
en los derechos humanos el gobierno de
daniel ortega es una estructura partido
familia gobierno que como he dicho
anteriormente ha cooptado en todos los
sectores sociales y naturalmente implica
que el país no se desarrolle que no
crezca económicamente que no crezcan
culturales socialmente ni políticamente